[Musique]
on l'attend
maidan place de l'indépendance
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie a
débuté il ya quelques heures kiev est
sonné
je n'ai aucun contrôle sur cette
situation moi et les autres on ne sait
pas quoi faire dès 6 heures du matin les
gens commençaient à fuir kiev
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient partait mais il
y a beaucoup de monde sur les routes
les russes ont attaqué plusieurs zones
du pays avec un appui aérien
kharkiv personnes ou marioupol sont
quelques-unes des villes bombardées
depuis trois semaines
mais les ukrainiens résiste
la victoire éclair souhaité par vladimir
poutine n'aura pas lieu la population
vit au rythme des sirènes à kiev comme
ailleurs elle retentissent plusieurs
fois par jour pour inviter les
ukrainiens se réfugier dans des abris
anti bombardements ce jour là la
capitale sort d'un couvre-feu strict de
long de trente six heures alors malgré
l' alerte ils patientent devant les
quelques magasins encore ouverts
mon mari a fait un malaise cardiaque
alors j'ai besoin de médicaments et
toutes les pharmaciens sont pas ouvertes
rien prévoir on a des hauts et des bas
c'est très difficile de se sentir comme
ça
surtout quand vous devez parler à votre
famille vos enfants quittent vous devez
rester fort ne pas montrer que vous avez
peur alors qu'on a vraiment peur
à cause des combats environ 3 millions
de personnes auraient déjà quitté
l'ukraine et il y aurait 2 millions de
déplacés dans le pays selon les nations
unies
à la gare de kiev quelques trains
fonctionnent encore pour les autres ce
sera la route
mais le trajet dangereux les russes
peuvent attaquer à tout moment
les barrages sont nombreux
les ukrainiens en âge de combattre ont
pris les armes
lui était avocat avant l'invasion
ordonnée par moscou
nous ne sommes pas les agresseurs on
veut juste défendre notre terre on
essaie de s'organiser on a reçu des
armes et on les donne aux gens mais il
n'y en a pas assez pour défendre toutes
les zones
nous on est une armée de 40 millions
d'ukrainiens vraiment notre force c'est
notre état d'esprit tout le monde veut
aider les gens nous apportent de la
nourriture et essaye de nous donner tout
ce dont on a besoin
à quelques 30 kilomètres de là dans une
zone encore épargné par les combats
sergei qui se prépare a passé la nuit
seul dans un hôtel
il a choisi de retourner à kiev malgré
le danger
un choix difficile a annoncé à ses
parents
pourquoi poutine fait ça pourquoi
faut-il pleurer nos merdes ukrainienne
j'ai parlé à ma mère aujourd'hui elle
comprend pourquoi je dois être à kiev
mes coéquipiers pas ou qu
il y a tant de gens qui ont fui la ville
du coup certains doivent rester pour la
défendre
c ette
sergei est ingénieur depuis l'invasion
il ne travaille plus et ne pensent qu'à
aider comme il peut
ma conviction c'est que je n'ai pas le
droit de tuer un autre homme
mais s'il le faut si les russes entrent
pour s'emparer de kiev alors je ne sais
pas comment je réagirais
réveil à l'aube un prêt pour le départ
lui et ses amis doivent apporter des
médicaments et de la nourriture
mon ami qui doit venir me chercher ici
ne répondent plus au téléphone
je ne sais pas il est peut-être mort
il fait partie des forces d'auto défense
de la vie nous essayer
tout peut arriver
ok je vais devoir aller à kiev à pied
alors
il part seul
alors que de nombreuses familles elles
font le chemin inverse
sur les routes des files d'attenté se
forment devant les stations service
l'essence est devenue une denrée rare et
surtout essentiel pour fuir
comme tant d'autres cette famille
traumatisée a dû tout abandonner
ils attaquent sans distinction quelle
que soit la nationalité la langue ou la
race moi je suis russe arménienne et les
russes cherchent à me tuer parce que
j'aime l'ukraine où je vis
les russes ont bombardé cette ville de
bilad servent qu'à située à 80
kilomètres de kiev qu'il cherche à
encercler
les forces ukrainienne patrouilles sont
relâche elle traque les groupes de
saboteurs russe
les russes pensaient que ces lettres
facile comme lorsqu'ils ont pris la
crimée qu'ils allaient pouvoir occuper
notre sol ukrainien
sans même avoir besoin de tirer une
balle mais c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe
je veux m'adresser aux soldats russes
les gars venaient ici
et vous allez voir comment on va bien
vous accueillir
l'ingénieur sergueï lui a finalement
réussi à rejoindre kiev ils nous
envoyaient des vidéos des stocks de
nourriture et médicaments qu'ils
distribuent
je suis très fier de toutes ces
personnes qui ont créé tout un réseau
d'entre aide pour nos citoyens
nos militaires
ainsi que les forces de défense
territoriale
je suis tellement ému quand je vois le
nombre de personnes qui participent
qui ne dorment pas suffisamment certes
mais qui font tout ce qu'elles peuvent
pour aider
son réseau est aussi les civils à
emprunter les couloirs humanitaires pour
fuir kiev direction la pologne ou la
moldavie les hommes doivent rester
combattre c'est la loi alors sur le pont
qui relie l'ukraine et la moldavie des
femmes et des enfants
ces familles ne savent souvent pas dans
quel pays d'europe elles iront elles
rêvent surtout de pouvoir un jour
revenir en ukraine